all right and we are live welcome to the
i lords podcast episode number 7070 it's
another glorious we are back at the
round table and the Lord's Day don't
know where our special guest is just yet
hopefully we can figure this thing out
man Louis ah forget it Darrell but of
course you know we have the Four
Horsemen of gaming those usual suspects
at the roundtable my co-hosts with the
cool most my brother from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
howl of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict how are you doing sir what's
going on you guys sound like a rough
night at the office man was used at the
bar last night what's going on the first
one I have a mini read on that oh we go
get it okay how how is it gang go to be
in game preview and these $60 because
the game is finished like why would it
go and preview on xbox when it's
finished elsewhere the game is finished
like I don't understand why it's in
preview on Xbox of course we have our
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
darkness mister offline profile
Illuminati of the iron bank my man Louis
sovereign are you doing sir what's up
guys doing well man I got to get up get
out last night after two weeks of like
being locked in with foam I got to get
my lip blonde or
the Leblon smelling all sterling or the
Lord's will be like to eat the greatest
and finest meats of the land finest
drinks and was a little beyond what's
the real Brazilian cop-con coppery nose
you know the company cutting the meat up
next
smorgasbord of food all over this place
is the gluttonous place on the planet
the most gluttonous place on the planet
if you want to go there and engorge
yourself in anything possible it is
right there all types of the ladies with
the drink bar and if your table is
popping they hit you with the brown
right now listen the Leblon is so
delicious
it's so delicious this is the first time
I've ever spent $200 on myself most of
that was on LeBlanc's a cheap cheaper
this is something we kind of do annually
you don't say look you did twice lomar
looniest
Lord Chi ba Chi was in the building
and wasps for that was excellent uh
funny nice change of pace from infinity
war and and then the gut punch but I
leave it
yeah well too much but uh make sure you
see it you know therapeutic infinity war
real quick I wanted to say something
real quick over a tree on stuff because
since our last show we've gotten four
more patrons and I don't want to wait a
month to give these guys that so I
wanted this real quick go through it go
for the first Oh first off Lord whiskey
himself quarry lytic thank you so much
bro that's an interview part an integral
part of the iron Lords thank you for the
support brother that's amazing mm-hm
the PlayStation brah thank you thank I'm
so pissed that I haven't met you yet but
I heard you an amazing person thank you
so much mm-hmm Lord J Fonz always
building repping the Lord so thank you
so much dude oh that's good yes sir and
last but certainly not least Lord
optimist cold
lord thank you so much brother really
appreciate the support you guys are
amazing absolutely amazing this stuff
just thank you so much at the bottom of
our hearts um real quick another Lord
Lord snail killer himself Diago per drop
yes sir no but snail killer has an issue
where it's difficult for us to get him
his rewards when he's won because of his
geography um and he won the $20.00 a
gift card this past time and he was it's
just difficult to get it to him so
mm-hmm
he graciously wants us to put it up in
the chat for somebody to grab today oh
wow so
so guys thank you Lord Iago Padre that
is amazing selfless on your part we
really appreciate that skies and attack
lookout for a cold later on at some
point during the show not gonna say when
it's gonna drop it's gonna be in there
saluted yeah absolutely yeah good doing
good
awfully definitely shout-out to all the
Lords of the iron bank they protect us
to protect the realm keep us financed
keep this thing going and of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
XS game the lord of combat sports was a
man of his convictions that man is
nothing less than that premium
experience and is to get money game up
beloved Lord King how you doing sir let
me tell you something I'm not even
getting into combat sports why because
if you want to see combat sport you got
to go to IOP channel I wouldn't because
I'm about to throw you in a fire right
now
right check it out we are moving in
these Facebook streets we are moving in
these Instagram streets and these
Twitter streets and on Twitch check it
out Lord addict is head of the stream
team the stream team will be bringing
you ILP content on a 24/7 basis it will
be 5 days out of the week and on the
Lord's Day you might catch a Lord
playing so I want y'all to check that
out now when you go to the Instagram the
Instagram will have pitches and
behind-the-scenes videos and everything
up that you really don't get a chance to
see on either the YouTube channel or you
don't need to see on Twitter but it's
there and the Facebook the Facebook will
give you upcoming events and stuff like
we're at and ways to purchase but also I
want y'all to be on the lookout because
we're wrapping things up and we keep on
moving and keep on growing with the pure
gaming theme this is mirror gaming we
want
only gamers to gain with us so pack your
gaming theme and we're moving forward
with that when we get down with our
partners where you can get that
exclusive merchandise you understand
what channel 5 is about real real
kung-fu stuff mm-hmm talk that so of
course we're I'm looking forward to it
man we got a lot things going in our
shout to Lord King in our attic for
spearheading stream team and the social
media movements you know saying so
that's that is what's up and of course
we have the gaming ninja himself the
shinobi lore kognito spread that realest
in the realm of the IOP not telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear so um there was a little bit of
UFC last night saw I don't know if you
saw anything completely missed it
literally literally it'll be one minute
Santos main event boring be one decision
um Chad Mendes came back he fought um
surgery long hiatus beautiful one round
knockout it was great and the the golden
boy brother sage Northcutt it was a
surfer looking guy got its own that the
USC chapter he finally got his first win
at welterweight so she salute him
cracked up in the face real hard he
almost got dropped out in first but oh
yeah do come with a stiffly left hand
and in the middle of a brawling exchange
and when he got up he toughed it out and
he was actually getting grounded out on
the floor but then he bounced ball yeah
man he came back didn't quit no he did
not quite like with T's a shout out
please make sure y'all watch combat talk
man King is out there killing it right
now that is amazing so that was pretty
much what it is but he a great win for
him TKO win so shout out to that brief
UFC little outro so anyway while we wait
hopefully a loss southbound be able to
join us in progress but until then want
to get it into what the Lord's are
playing so long addict even was dead yet
some issues with
what else you could bloom while I'm
playing divinity one I've been switching
back and forth from variety of different
games it's on xbox and I played a little
bit of moonlighters - that's about all
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the loss would you blame em my
playstation xbox has seen no burn in the
last like literally have not been turned
on the last two weeks - were crazy all
which business and so - that and they've
been raping my pockets I picked up the
holo night that is a fantastic game they
should have gotten the burn that they
deserved last year when they came out on
PC and it just didn't happen and now
that it's out on switch you know it's an
ideal sort of game force which people
are reviewing it now like it's kind of a
brand new game is kind of crazy so it's
always good that like brand new unfair
like but it comes with a flavor I got
that and then I might toad treasure
tracker which is I did not play on the
Wii U and by the looks of that picture
that King put up neither did he game was
also well my junk when I purchased it I
purchased it from my with you my Wii U
was downstairs when the basement and
stuff was getting done so I actually
forgot about that game so when I was
going downstairs to play my Wii U the
other day I was like oh wow this just
came out on switch look at what's funny
is that I thought that game was only
digital I didn't even know they
add a physical version on the week you
have ago okay so beyond that oh my game
of the Year contender chicken no one of
these games that I was looking forward
to really bad so it's wrong chicken
sauce please explain this chicken is a
load of game look it's it has on that
Yoshi's Island art style that's real
pretty to look at but basically it's
like a 2d platformer slash like puzzle
game so basically you're a chicken
mm-hmm viewed with the powers from the
Lord above it viewed with the powers lay
bombs right you're born in this facility
where you know chickens get their get
guy you know beauty with these powers to
be able to escape and help your brethren
escape so you do like you just you lay
bombs and then you find you you make
your way out of this Wow for your the
platforming stuff the cool little puzzle
stuff you do like the physics stuff you
do with the bombs it is like it's really
well made I can see why King David when
he saw it was like yeah this is funny I
gotta get this been doing it for many
told me he don't eat chicken so that's
pretty much what it is been said a bomb
chicken game or accident some Mario
Tennis online that old man is crazy
Lord King what have you in place her
oh this week I've been definitely
getting all my destiny stuff up shout
out the Lord Fastback who jumped inside
on my chat
like I like the fact that first of all
my party's is always open so if you
follow me on xbox so you know we're
friends on Xbox you just jump in and we
talk we play games jumping in discretion
display verdict as would he be yes what
is in this well girls are in that party
does not represent what iron Lords is is
two different kings I'm gonna tell you
right now my kids watch this show
alright my kids are not in my chat
alright so knowing that part right there
and fast fact will attest to that like
wow King is really loose more that
thanks Kay yeah so listen y'all y'all
jump in but what we was doing was if you
part of our destiny claim I've won you
to your night falls I bring you to all
the stuff that you got to get through we
want people through they are the rates
shout out the Lord are monkeys and death
for actually finishing the race for the
first time we took them to the raid they
got done but I was man that was serious
um but I played a couple of weakened
games like I said oh I'm not gonna
really get into those because there was
really really throwbacks like Donkey
Kong Country and all that um I played
this game called Technomancer on xbox it
is 60 frames per second is in game pass
it is 60 frames per second I think it's
native 4k I don't know but the game is
like some sideshow game it has me
entranced for it's it's like a super B
game like a suit like you like B movies
if you like B movies you will love this
game like it's it's fun and you see the
flaws you see what they was trying to do
but they work they own little mojo so
this is my little project that I'm
playing but if you want to check out a
good game that looks really good techno
man
techno maze
you see how much is per meal now we
could lucky that we could check it out
King that Lord caused me to really wants
to know is it on the switch to switch
points of stuff but we gave pass out
that changes things like free is
undefeated my mind is free to crucible
all day you know saying so it's the UM
iron banner you know I'm saying shadow I
saw some Lords right quick man shot
Malloy's Punk dis game and always in the
fridge crucible at the heavy
you don't say taking a heavy making
himself look extra good now B's man I
was definitely had a lot of fun with me
a beast when you shoot rockets at people
there was a couple batches with cuz I'd
be funny with a heavy spawn and like you
see who's chillin at the fridge late the
cash out before you need to start using
that heavy more I'll only on I grabbed
it because I don't want them to have it
say I've never used oh you're buggin
that's that's probably why we lost maybe
a few matches hey you've got to use that
every bit like the 20 games we played I
might have my game four of them no I
know a lot of people don't like it they
fail so much every but I just love the
fact that like I said everyone has I
mean that it spawns quicker and that it
rewards the skilled player for killing
you know that person who has heavy by
giving them heavy loved and I said like
I'm a flash player but anyway or whom it
also want to shadow Lord addict of
course doing this thing to assist a
relevant native man you get some sweaty
trials of a shout out there headband he
was like y'all I gotta work on you
call-outs I was like you know what right
and we started improving to shout out
the yo society irrelevant and of course
Lord much was in the building you know
saying with yeah I've an attic we zoom
in you know I'm a with Jeff on teasing
on his uh his uh Guardians closed so his
close game you gotta step that up but a
little shuts out there with a chess
piece over than that nothing as a good
run and dome yeah man had a good time
playing a lot of that as far as switch
it was still on my banner saga grind I'm
trying to get that out cuz uh part two
dropped and then they just put part
three is gonna be coming on the eShop so
I gotta get these games done had a lot
of fun with that and another thing Laura
saw one of my classics favorite of all
time another world dropped or the
smaller yeah so I had to pick it up I
pick up um which got another world
literally on every platform a drop it
doesn't matter what generation that's
one of my favorite games of all time and
that game I believe where we had our
Lord Jacobus horn was created all by one
man that game that's insane so shout out
to the legendary another world in the
library now on switch so we go get into
last platforms please make sure that you
do that because unknowing so a lot of
people oh yeah she gets Breslin she gets
busy I've been with Trina strays I'm
trying to catch it
yeah she definitely get our buggy up and
cries well last week's poll last week
was on actually with rumors of next
generation consoles appearing to be
releasing much sooner than later
how do you feel about the current
generation of consoles coming to a close
the winner at 53% in a fairly close
three-way ILP poll is the current
generation is over too soon this
generation was just hitting its stride
group so that was first place coming in
at second at 39% was the current
generation is too underpowered bring on
the next gen consoles and yes really 8%
was I don't care
y'all don't want that smoke would go any
grow so the left means coke what do the
Lord's think about the people go I'm not
ready for the next generation it seems
whether the British guys got to think
about that so any any but you feel I
mean it's whatever they don't want it to
have to buy I love here and play on the
Xbox one like they plan on the 360 for
eight years before no no no I'm
surprised you would say that because you
seem like resistant like when X came out
a little bit like you don't care about
four - because it's not a next-gen
hardware it's it's what we have now just
a little extra okay unless it's a new
bump
I don't want old bump just a little
advil you don't want the bum bum bum bum
solve what you came in I mean listen my
thing is whenever it does come out it
could be two years after the initial
launch if it drops I'm getting it so
like I you know I can play devil's
advocate and say you know whatever the
proper thing the same but I'm getting it
regardless - when it comes out so if it
was if it's a two years out a year out
five years whatever but I think the base
councils have been out for five years
now that goes that brings it back to you
know the release cadence of before the
360 and ps3 era like we just got you
know people got forward with that
got to remember that 360 and ps3 lasted
as long because of the economic
situation in the country where it was
not viable for them to announce another
$400 machine in 2000
you know 2008 2009 so can can we agree
that if this thing comes out next year
that mid generation consoles were
useless it's just gonna bring up it's
just gonna bring us like two years
before the system came out with
generation if it comes out next year
that means they're trying to force-feed
us the two year you know phone thing and
you know for me that's fine it'll work
maybe some people won't like that but
the fact the matter is I don't saw it
useless I don't think so not at all like
I said I love my ex play I think you got
a you got a really convinced people with
these upgrades then because you can
bring it out next year that means 2021
you're bringing out the upgrade got you
know down yeah I mean it's interesting I
think I think I kind of felt that way I
didn't know how home the rest of the
Lords did what if it drops I'm gonna
pick it up but oh my god want it no I I
did my ex hasn't been maxed out so brah
until you can till you show me games
that shows me the potential of my system
that I just spent five hundred dollars
on put that other stuff in the bushes
show me the reason why I got abandon
this hardware that you just sold me some
the newest greatest has all this
technology inside of it that you ain't
need to use yet and that you're gonna
tell me yoga knows honestly this is
right no I'm
oh we're not gonna do no cell phone
model that I'm gonna embrace I'm gonna
buy it because I'm a fool but no I wanna
see Ruiz note that goes cell phone model
is
much as I hate to say this I'll go to PC
gaming at the end of the day if you if
you're forced migration people every
couple like two to three years what
about even it would forward um
compatibility that wouldn't no I'd
rather be on PC brought them that's the
reason I have an Xbox like crazy thing
is that people resistant to that but
these consoles are cheaper than a new
phone moves coming at you King he says
see at these water push the Xbox one
next to his Spencer selling wouldn't
Nichols out he owed a going in right now
at the end of the day I feel like mid
generation consoles are worthless
because it can't take advantage of that
mid generation consoles by the time they
can they already on the next-gen
consoles like it's just no but you know
taking advantage of this system that
PlayStation is dope let's keep it a
hundred did that God bring out the Last
of Us
that goes to Tsushima they just told me
anybody thought it was next-gen hardware
they just said not that's that
PlayStation Pro that you purchase is
right there you're gonna get it it's
going to be checkerboard but what you
see here is what you get so you're
telling me that okay you're gonna bring
out the PlayStation 5 you talk about it
but these games that look graphically
incredible
you're maxing out this system that I
paid $400 for Thank You Sony I
appreciate Microsoft all day damn Lee
alright because you did not show me
right now stop with the forces telling
me talking about poor Z he just means
the big mag not too small I want you to
really think about this if for the cars
look like the cars like when you walked
outside and saw him in the street like
if you really was photorealistic Sony is
pushing their system to the point that
it's incredible right
Microsoft is telling you that we have
more power than this but I don't see so
when I see it
then I'm going to move so what's right
now that be honest with you I'm more
inclined to buy a Playstation 5 ahead of
an Xbox because of the fact and Mac they
joint out those engines and those days
we gotta give credit man they took they
they definitely really maximized you see
games like Detroit you see games you
know saying like God of War it really
looks good you know Jonathan but you
gotta stop checkerboard game wait
witcher 3 will verse 9 - and more
playing on my ex meeting more than
working I'm fine with the men generation
up great especially for Xboxes to base
GPU so we salute Lord
500 purchases worth 2 games but you
realize the upgrade because you're not
there like that's let me tell you how a
Ferrari feels if you're driving a penny
that when you were just raging about 30
cuz technically we would laugh in an
attic for that upgrading right withdrew
the XV like alright
now you tell me that that buildings are
different
uh no that's in the right knowing you
it's a young problem you me the donut
shop that's all that's on that's on the
block it's just not there but it's there
on the X yeah
all I'm saying oh I got I got this video
for it and I saw it with sinister we're
playing pop G one time shot the los
sinister the buildings weren't even
loaded in yet it looked at like clay
models on screen Wow there is a
difference then your system it's you
okay my nose got a Vaseline scream and
mine is very crisp and clean there's no
reason for you to upgrade to a
Playstation 4 new Xbox you know you
gotta stay in this generation where it's
not for okay okay okay but the 4k it's
really pushing 4k they talk about 8k
you ain't even get to 4k these documents
that you've seen on the so they have
videos up there of running games on the
next-generation
waiting for divas show me the sling
next the small digital foundry I see
that you do not go there so if the X
becomes the base console right
everything's for compatible you become
will you get the X and hold that phone
you think that now they're not leaving
it they're not leaving it behind like no
they were there I can leave it behind
but they're not gonna make it to base
they're not gonna make a next generation
because when you have that when you have
the ps5 coming out out and it's got a
way better CPU and they're pushing out
games that have way more advanced [ __ ]
when it comes to on the CPU side then
Xbox is lost
Oh what I mean what I mean by base look
they're gonna be the only stations for
they're gonna leave the PlayStation 4 in
the dust this is what you're saying so
you believe there's gonna be five
exclusives I guarantee you that mmm
let me ask you this attic do you think
that the um so you don't think there's
gonna be backward compatibility when PS
5 drops digested your bedroom I don't
think they're going hasn't showed me one
thing that they're doing [ __ ] like that
now they came out multiple times said
they don't need that but I mean look
they've been the most anti consumer this
generation they feel like they don't
need it it's possible you you got to
look at it from the standpoint like
people be acting like they just started
research and development these they
started doing that two three years ago
mmm facts what they really didn't need
it and before even expert I would say if
I would have put a number I would say
they probably started working on it
around when the original Xbox at the the
the Xbox X when that started that's when
they started the ps4 the ps5 because if
you want my honest opinion I think the X
was just a prototype of next generation
mmm
was it Phil or was it Mike Mike Ibarra
might have been on this guy that left
them Albert Panello who said they that
when they when the exit of the original
Xbox one came out they already had in
mind what they wanted to do with the X
what they wanted the X to be right
whether they had specs down or not no
but they knew that was coming
they were doing the iterative thing
right okay the reason why we talk about
visuals so much is because visuals
actually push the industry forward
visuals give you that pop let me explain
first attic before you go into your
whole tirade of playing these little
indie crap okay hold an industry back so
visual but he don't want the smoke so
he's trying to give you smoke screens
know why we were talking about the Last
of Us look good nobody will talk about
ghosts of Hashima if it look good you
don't know nothing about the gameplay
all you see is the visuals and you like
oh my god
this is the next level so let's let's
start that part right there gameplay
comes when you get a chance to touch it
but what brings you in is the visuals
right so that's why we talk about
visuals Aaron all right that's my point
I was answering the chats question
before you jumped up with your hold let
me stop him now crap how did get off all
I have to say is there's been games that
I've been directed to look good but
sucked and have low Metacritic scores
right now on Metacritic one for 1886
they made it to look phenomenal game son
final fantasy 15 game to make it look
phenomenal game son all rise
made it to look phenomenal game suck
easy being games or being dull eliciting
yes it's all I see what you're going to
I mean the thing is this adding and
you're you are correct is I mean look at
this so attic you have to admit what
king of say no on one side that a visual
the visuals of a game will at least draw
you in more that's the problem is good
that's what their priority is to show
you a good looking game that does that
plays I [ __ ] right but because that
those games in especially there's no
King said to move the industry forward
if they're trying to sell you a brand
new $500 piece of machine get them
straight let me get this straight
they're gonna owe me something
phenomenal like rise comes out cuz like
it's like a 68 because they look at the
game is a whole entity not visuals when
the game comes correct let me explain
something they don't sell you gameplay
when they're showing you a game so why
you acting like this
I understand what you're saying what
you're saying is you don't want the
industry to be based solely on this
graphic and I sell you alright
but it's very hard for you to get across
game played in a that that that
point-and-click type of thing people's
attention span is very short so if it's
not something that draws them in you
won't hold management I think don't look
good that's fast no because I remember
when art came out and he was like I look
[Music]
at the end of the day I got other new
features that we seen in games this
whole generation vote because people are
building games to look good but not play
good because they want it bring people
win listen I will say listen there's a
priority and yes this is a priority in
the Nemesis system that's all the
conversation now we if we want to talk
about what has the current generation
brought feature-wise you know as far as
innovation you got an argument on that
we're just talking about when a game is
made and it's presented right you have
to admit if something looks phenomenal
at a press conference or a trailer
preview that's what kind of draws you in
first then sometimes the other game like
an indie game or something else that may
not have that kind of visual punch you
find out later out gameplays really
don't and then the word spreads and then
get gets out first but that type again
the second game I mentioned it's hard to
compete with the first game that just
looks phenomenal off rip you can't
understand what I'm getting at with that
cuz you're not wrong I'm just talking
about as far as what lures a game around
entices a game but it kind of follow a
game you wanna mean game where I'm
coming like I'm tired of games being
it's like it's like I brought up Final
Fantasy 15 earlier like it's like they
spent the whole system the entire budget
on making the summons mmm no I feel and
and knack and that's where you have an
argument that some of these companies
have lost their way
as far as full baby or over focus on it
and I get that that's where maybe you
have your frustration engine but damage
topic with lone shout the Lordaeron
summers he got us going to apologize
that was fantastic
yeah we love banter like that so it's
all good pleased chat we learn at MIT so
we go get into these topics so arm is
gonna be a two-part I'm gonna set this
thing off here at the round table
star part one so it's either
d endless a great friend Matt piscatella
is in the deal is against all friends of
the show yeah of course and um yeah so
it looks like he's got his predictions
going out right now and he even though
PlayStation 4 has maintained the number
one spot for MPD basically this whole
generation all year he claims the switch
is poised to take the number one
position by quarter fall of 2018 he says
we could ship it right now but you
asking me but not only not ps4 off its
throne for the quarter in the end but it
will be the best-selling console of the
year he quotes from Pokemon let's go
he Smash Brothers and he also he said
that um besides the fourth quarter you
actually had a list of also his arm top
ten games and what I thought was
interesting about his time he saw
forecasts for 2018 out of the top ten I
thought thought about kicking our attic
my findings interesting was that he had
like Red Dead Redemption one called
Duty battlefield NBA 2k 19 for cry 5
Madden 19 for out 76 he's got number
seven
God of War still at 8 in the top 10
Monster Hunter world 9 and then he's
rounding it out top 10 with marvel
spiderman so pretty solid list as far as
you know the top 10 sellers of 2018 but
what I did find interesting you know to
the Lord is that he didn't have actually
80 switch titles at his top 10 so one
what do the lords think about this do we
think this forecast is accurate by Matt
piscatella Lord Chris Keller and to also
about that top 10 you don't mean all the
listing games for best selling games of
2018 so let's start with a lord addict
what do you feel about this sir I think
it's possible they can be MPD's for the
year mm I mean it's only America I feel
like that's where the bulk of the sells
for the switch is coming from right now
as an end yes
what wait wait wait you can't discount
destroying it's not even close
I mean I didn't say all of the cells are
coming
America yeah but Japan is the huge yes
platoon is like number one out there
like know what they know yeah like they
might be you know do for the most part
like let's be real all the games coming
out is coming out on two platforms that
chances are everyone has a switch as at
least one of them mm-hm and or PC or
less i tech pc because i've read dad's
not coming out on pc o much but like i
don't think it's been announced or
hasn't been announced has been hinted a
kinda now i understand your point low
Sam he's saying that as far as the top
selling games that a year remember that
Nintendo doesn't provide digital numbers
which has actually been shows the more
impressed with Nintendo but where I
disagree loss Sam is that I still feel
Pokemon will ship will be on that list I
feel he's being serviced coming out in
November and pokemons always about a
like but it's not gonna be the first mom
it would my it might push on me you got
to think it's gonna push out like maybe
I would say three to four million in the
first one right and you got read dad
probably gonna push 10 million the first
month right so you so you do you think
he was over conservative with the top 10
of 2018 games like you feel that a
switch game will crack that top 10 so
here's the thing that those two
platforms are out they've been out for
longer than the switch a lot more people
have those two platforms right well when
you draw Super Smash Brothers and
Pokemon within a month of each other
that is a reason to buy switch and
you're gonna have flocks of people
buying a switch and buying that and the
reason that they're not gonna be on the
top 10 to the the most selling games is
because there's already 70 plus billion
ps4 is that you just go out and buy the
game for there's already 40 million put
yes I said 40 million you got to get
over yourself
Oh million Xbox ones that you could just
go out and buy on a switch not so much
because
gonna have to buy it to get in it's not
are we going it Lord solve what do you
feel about this man they switch with a
switch would be the best in 2018 I mean
I hit the nail on the head really
they've been you know which is what a
year not even a year and a half old yet
but I wouldn't be surprised if it didn't
went to mmm I mean and you mentioned
something last week addict about how do
you think there would probably be a red
dead bundle for PlayStation 4 or
something like that so that's gonna move
it's gonna move PlayStation units my
thinking on that sort of stuff is like
what you said this no 80 million place
they start their 40-minute Xboxes most
people have those consoles already so I
don't see consoles moving per se
the thing is it games Playstations been
winning the whole year so it's gonna
have to drastically sell the last couple
months to the equivalent of renting 6-7
MPD's but I think to me like it's like
you said people more than for
PlayStation more than for an Xbox will
become a Nintendo console in for those
Nintendo properties but if you think if
you look at it from the perspective of
last year on like the holiday sells that
whole November in December even that
long than drastic of a difference but
between the cells right it won't close
they're pretty close yeah if we get a
similar thing like that there's no way
they'd be PlayStation they might be an
Xbox there's a good chance they'll beat
Xbox but I don't see them still so let
me ask you this lordy what about bugging
was talking about that the power of the
two arm Pokemon games and you yourself
said that Smash Brothers is a last aisle
P you said that's a system so like oh
it's a system solar but it's like I said
they would have they would have to
dramatically sell that because
Playstations gonna go off the shelves
too you know they're having that
discounted bundle you know the rather
than the this flame on discounted
they're gonna have that red dead bundle
right no people max up in Grand Rose
mm-hmm they would I would say for them
to win MPD's from losing half the year
they would have to push at least six to
six hundred to 1.5 million more than the
rest so now you sound like you don't
no I said that I I could see them doing
it but all I see them not doing all
right so pretty much you feel it like
it's close okay back in the chat said
this we didn't win last year and during
the holidays with Mario which is true
but I'll tell you this it's something
about there's an accessibility to smash
and is an accessibility to Pokemon that
Mario doesn't have a zealot is over okay
my people love Zelda by Zelda is coda
consider like a hardcore game it's not
like your average kid who feeds who goes
to Nintendo is not me like I wonder
Edwards kid right now is playing for not
on their mobile phone with what I'm
saying is that Zelda Zelda is a system
seller for guys like us necessarily
Pokemon Pokemon Pokemon alright I know
you changing there
I wanna I want to just say this I want
to say you know I like my piscatella um
I do find him a friend of the realm but
this is clickbait all right up inside
you had none of those titles up in your
top 10 alright so that you know in your
heart that it wasn't going anyways
you're hoping hold on shadows or loss in
that remember Nintendo they don't count
any digital numbers accounting plate
numbers that means Zelda Mario on MPD
are winning without their hold on
without their digital number we can't
get it to hyperbole now yeah I gotta
give it up yeah rock for what yo these
two made a point right so you got one
guy saying no then he then he's saying
but I can see it though you got another
guy that you know there's the pie in the
sky guy that believes here it could
happen I'm telling you it ain't gonna
happen
alright I don't know I don't care about
what they sell I don't care what they're
trying to do I don't care what is
happening with them that Smash Brothers
ain't gonna make it happen in a poke
it's not gonna happen but you won't bend
the knee with it let's go I'll take you
bet I take your bet let's go I take ok
thank you
alright so now that your bed is taken
that's just letting you know that I
believe Matt was click baiting anyway oh
I don't I don't feel that way because I
know that these the Xbox and the
PlayStation Black Friday and the
Christmas sales is gonna happen when the
Christmas cells because they poison
myself to jump over to the next ship
actually they're in a battle and both
these ships got holes in it and they
sinking so what they trying to do just
offload stuff all right so you're gonna
start getting discounted systems
original og Xbox cheat s is cheap
reginal Playstations cheap or the
original xbox is no option anymore yeah
well it's not so you can get it for
basically free so um these things is
gonna start happening where it's gonna
make it hard for the switch so you say
these people that didn't get switched
yet right that want to switch so bad all
right so a couple of million here a
couple of million there I do not think
it's gonna outpace the other two guys so
even if it's close and even if they
outsell them in software I don't really
believe they're gonna outsell them and
hard work for the simple fact that they
are going to move I believe Xbox will
move a little bit more to PlayStation
because there's more Playstations out
there but I believe PlayStation because
it's in more regions and it has a
foothold and biggest markets it will
steep it will keep its dominance all the
way through for the rest of the year
okay fair enough I mean I are you making
good points I'm not bigoted okay that it
cuz I did a biggest thing for I just
want to address the like the digital
thing yes I just like me personally I
just don't feel like a whole lot of
people addicts world doesn't mean the
world doesn't do it we gotta stop I just
I'm not lettin out does not hit the
eShop that is but I'm going from step
from what we know I'm not hyperbole Rock
let me talk no but I'm just let you know
that these new sales are not counted
you're trying to tell me I'm not saying
I'm not saying that I'm just saying that
I don't think it's like huge numbers or
anything why do you not think it's used
because you have to have with the Xbox
and ps4 if you bought a game you bought
an Xbox or a ps4 you sat down you hook
that up you can at least get that game
majority of switch games that you
my digital you have to download on
fortnight is completely online it's the
number one switch game right now oh but
it's not ah because if they're not
counting the digital sales right does it
go up against the MPD's if they knock
out okay this is what I'm saying
alright because you're both right right
your boat I hear the argument and being
that MPD's is not being counted for this
digital and I believe the bulk of switch
sales is in digital that's what Eric is
saying is a non-factor because if it's
not being counted I don't care how much
they're selling when it comes to this
argument it does it shows how amazing
what they're doing put those numbers up
though Mike wasn't a numbers up they was
getting ridiculed right put the numbers
up I mean the lack of digital numbers on
the eShop is probably attributed to the
fact that the eShop is kind of a mess
right
they probably say how much we sold this
week no they wait they waiting for that
$20 a year then they'll let you know
what they suffer I could say I just I
just disagree Jimmy I just disagree with
this whole nonsense that digital is not
being counted you don't say you could
reverse that if there's no actual not no
tangible things that you could put your
hand around to know them okay there's no
tangible thing can we agree that it's
what's being tangible there's more to
add to it can we agree that and then you
add an unknown quantity that is more
than that will be used together in the
APD's it's no I say that again with
people he's right he's right he's right
this is still me your ghost is the
lineup so get your ghost delino would be
a hundred like two switches to a massive
numbers digitally if they if they had a
better storage unit but that's because a
lot of people would have to go out spend
more money on an SD card to even
download a low key mandatory based on
the fact that the internal was so low
light it's this Pokemon like I don't
know how most pokemons do really well
but this is the one that I don't know
what's gonna do because it's not your
standard Pokemon game right that is crap
oh c'mon go did really well but a lot of
people that play pokemon go they took it
for what it was right I don't know
people are gonna be down for bringing
those features into their poke
come on game okay so that's gonna affect
their overall sales there you go if
Pokemon doesn't have a decline in sales
because of that between that and super
they have a good chance of beating MPD I
think I think that's not gonna affect it
that much they know that the real ones
coming if they had no idea that I mean
don't the cash is gonna see that as the
new Pokemon game they're good they're
gonna look up let's go Pikachu which is
a wack name but we don't look at that
trailer and be like that's some Pokemon
go what you some like that some won't
because there's a lot of Pokemon people
that played that 10 years ago that stop
playing it they bought a switch and
they're gonna look at them like that
doesn't look like Pokemon talk I can't
get the point off but when he's got all
this points out I'll be ready to go go
okay
I'm not gonna get interrupted this time
alright so this is what I'm saying now
job me crazy here's the deal and we got
a stop and I hate this with hardcore
gamers we have to stop living in this
bubble that what we feel and what we
think is gospel right we have to think
from the mindset of you know what
there are casual people who don't have
all this information and hey they're
just gonna get a Pokemon game oh hey the
new smash brothers is coming out or
whatever now in reference to Matt Chris
could tell his whole thing you know
saying it could go either way I'm going
King actually I'm actually what ad
excuse me in that respect that it could
go either way this thing is gonna be
close and I agree with you addict at the
end of last of 2017 you don't say it was
very close and ps4 definitely won the
NPD's the only thing we have to get away
from is the eShop thing and at that part
I'm not letting go because at the end of
the day that is a huge resource that is
growing constantly that is the number
one place for in these all over the
place regardless of the fact that the
eShop is a mess right as far as the way
things are organized and all that crap
you know say but as we know
with this we do know every indie
developer waits for the most part has
said their titles sell more on the
switch in the PS I wasn't talking about
the ad though it's up to my overall
point I'm getting it what I'm saying is
so we got that information from devs
they're telling us yo it sells more on
the platform that has the lowest it'll
be the install base that's lower than
then these two these two journeys so
that's the first point as far as the NPD
and the whole numbers with you know the
top ten and what King is saying I hear
what you're saying well red red dead you
know what's the other one call of duty
those platforms are not on a switch King
you got a strong on right destiny you
got a strong on it this thing is gonna
be close cuz at the end of the day those
are multi plants those are huge multi
plants that are not on that I'd say it's
the switch Xbox and ps4 all came out in
the same year there's no way but I feel
like the switch has a lot more ground to
make yeah I'm with you on that the thing
I stink though at the end of the day is
when it comes down to you have the big
ones right you got Pokemon regardless to
you know whether you know people view
it's gonna be the kids game that name in
itself carries tremendous weight
we've got smash with you yourself set
attic is a system seller those are the
two that I see map piscatella really
riding on and those two I agree with him
you know me and I think he's been but
remember they're not counting digital
cell I think that's a factor we can't
say that's not effective for two of the
huge most you just games on a platform
we can't and this is the only reason why
I have to call bogus on his claims okay
this is the only reason why if if you
claim that right because of these two
games right games right while they're
not in your top ten when he starts to
break down the top ten that's
ten he put up this strong argument at
least include one or two of them in the
top ten to push and fortify his argument
right listen that's the part that's the
only part of his forecast that I'm in
agreement I'm like okay let me see I
look at the digital aspect I look at it
not now even so in 2017 which was kind
of a yearís which we had games like
destiny win NPD we've had games that
were not on switch when NPD but still
switch one console and that's the point
yeah jump to IOPS my yeah the game was
that
remember Soph yeah that because the game
is in the top ten in the console I think
I think I'll say like I don't think you
can really count the first year consoles
out compared to consoles that's been out
for years about every month but that's
the combat but you could also say it's
unfair to the switch that has come in
late to the game would establish
consoles and that's the other thing you
know we're talking about console cells
not software cells right and it's coming
to the game late it dropped in what
March of 2017 did it I feel like last
year it's already behind I think I just
think I think those two games are going
to push console sales to the point where
they could definitely it could
definitely supersede the sales at that
moment I think you should now what I'm
think is the proximity of these games to
the end of the year doesn't give them a
lot of time to get up there in sales
like you talking about I got a counter
for that those off we also forget that
something that some of you this is one
thing Xbox does well they put a lot of
their things you know we get mad at them
right are there things in that for that
third quarter slash four quarter and
generate the most revenue a lot of times
right wrapping it in that holiday season
with a
everybody got money and everybody's
coming out you know I'm saying to go get
something that's all I'm saying and
here's the other thing that you're not
gonna like the other forecast is that by
quarter 2019 the switch will have most
likely of passed the Xbox one in overall
kachi ignored it like that and Dave the
hair and blowing I'm just don't care
about sales because I don't play sales
right so I don't that aspect is cool but
remember what I said these guys is like
they're they're on to the next like
they're literally on to the next right
and these Nintendo isn't so they're
marking empowering and stuff like that
dead games honestly and I told you
before all these games you get in this
video games you're gonna start getting
your switch games I believe at the end
of this year beginning of next year the
last game is a smash brothers that's the
last we you game and then everything
after that I will believe will be pure
switch titles and you're gonna start
seeing that change where graphically
they look better right they have a more
implementation with the controllers play
better do you guys think the e3 might
have heard it sells for the holiday it
was a three it was a three storm it was
a three wave storm the Kraken switches
the the to much on a smash brothers I
said it and the fact that they didn't
have enough of those big baby ticket
item titles like they really just stayed
on a smash brothers talked about the
Pikachu and didn't have another like
smash hit type of game like an adventure
game to go with the system so I believe
those three factors hurting I think else
doubling in in the week after
III though how do you explain that
it means they can't explain them still
surviving period poor games and these
games is actually selling gamers because
we look at graphical fidelity we look at
all these things in an our mind we're
like yo I'm not getting a switch for
that or this that the hard cool is like
laughing at this like how is this
happening but the sales keep reflected
like you said right cake it's like it is
and my kids is sitting there plans
anything they're on a stay plate I
switch if you see mice which one they're
playing it okay if they're playing Mario
Kart they're playing a digital stuff
listen I don't really purchase anything
they're playing all these party game for
that Mario Party so I don't care what
nobody says its selling to the casuals
my kids my son is hardcore but my kids
is casuals
so that's hardcore can we personally I
can't have a personal look at things
with a bigger perspective than just
yourself but I only speak for myself why
would I care about Johnny buying a
switch because that affects the old war
led numbers in this argument numbers
that don't exist that numbers numbers
guy the fact that the fact that their
point is valid in this they switches are
moving and I don't really believe the
hog I believe the hardcore already
brought with Zelda and everything that
bang that we
in the beginning when they sold like 10
million really quickly I believe that
was like the hard card I was like on it
everything after this I believe there
was people that was waiting for switches
to become available when they got a
chance to get it or they're gonna pick
up a game head and gonna pick up a game
there and they want to get it for their
kids or whatever the case may be I
believe that the casuals is pushing the
market like they did with the week all
right
um they have this casual market if you
don't want to believe it or not they're
dropping 30 indie titles a week I've
never heard that and ever or less less
for the record a lot of these indie
titles are digitally only titles I'm
cutting what Jesus talk about when I
talk about physical and digital I'm
talking about the actual games you can
buy physical at the store not the
digital games it's only release digital
obviously the only digital games are
gonna sell right but at the end of the
day but you said that no one the eShops
really not that a factor that it's an
unknown so come on like you can't have
it both ways now so I'm trying to say
let you be you not giving enough credit
we can't talk about that because we
don't know the number I just talked
about numbers that's digitally what are
you talking about but I'm talking about
physical games like Zelda games that's
what we're talking about
no we're talk about MPD which is the
games in November that we're saying is
gonna sell this system come on I can't
can I talk come on come on they both I'm
gonna - those two games okay do you
think they're gonna sell more physical
or digital what do you think if you were
to pretty percentage-wise on physical
and a percentage-wise
on digital with a mark of well you know
kamala nation we don't have the
information but that's my point why are
you coming at me wouldn't be fuzzy
because I'm coming at you because you
discount the digital this county I don't
think it's I yeah and I'm telling you
and then I'm sure you don't know yeah we
have
information that we had we do here's the
numbers I'm sure I'm gonna tell you this
a budget you want me to pull up every
developer developer you want me to pull
up every indie developer cuz I could
come up with a spreadsheet and send that
to you they have said our title switch
and has outsold the Xbox and Playstation
counterplay I can give you spreadsheets
so I want those sellers I added your I'm
not you change it please do not make
sense and you say you're changed we have
to stop acting like just because it
doesn't apply to us cuz we don't like it
or we don't think but we don't have that
information we have to stop making broad
statements that's all I'm saying is a
big sales that are not included in NPD
all I'm saying is MPD at the end of the
day still doesn't count that and that is
a disadvantage to the switch that's all
credit to me it's doesn't matter the
games that come out in November in
December or game selling it's like only
a caliber of a Zelda horrifying 80 games
because they're only digital obviously
I'm talking about the games that are
physical the games you go to the store
and buy those are going to be physical
if I were to give a percentage it would
be 70/30 we see I can't none of us don't
have real McCoy we don't have anybody
waters
moving the wash off let's watch moving
along
the fun part of the topic would be
what's going on with a switch
crack-a-lackin' so it's been found out
at the Tendo life did actual percentage
it looks like 20 over a thousand about
20 percent have cracks in the plastic
around the fan exhaust of the switch so
what's going on it looks like it's the
exact same crack at the top part what
events are and this is looked like it
might be a recurrent issue with a couple
people saying 20 percent of the of the
base and thing that's interesting about
it is it's descendants add that only is
it in the same space but Nintendo hasn't
been actually cooperative you know
saying they actually been are saying
almost like it's an accidental damage
thing and users in the UK Nintendo guys
in UK are pretty much saying that it's
over like 100 and 100 pounds you know
I'm saying just to get this thing you
know fixed so one how crack-a-lackin' is
this issue do we think this is like a
major issue do we think it's overblown
or do we think we have almost like a red
dead I mean right there a red ring it's
situation so let's start with more data
about the arm crack in the Nintendo
switch issue once people can't take care
they [ __ ] they buy minutes and oh you
think it might be on like oh just
overblown because of the 22 say or do
you think like yo we might have like a
red gig red rings situation like 360
I've seen like one or two videos if this
was like drastic I would be seeing the
no covering and I would be saying random
channels being popped this stuff up it's
a small percentage cracking I haven't
seen this being covered really at all
because you can suppress a lot of
information not stopping systems from
playing look
the problem they see if it was stopping
citizens from playing it will be
widespread it will be popping up but
it's not but I'm any news that's smaller
than this blow up I've seen new smaller
than this like that on the anti-consumer
thing that Sony did with banning the
account that blew up and that was one
person you mean to tell me that 20%
switches is blown up and I don't see yes
listen just like l-boogie said it's a
problem but it's not big enough for
recall you understand is not a situation
where you crack the screen is not
cracking it's the vents that's it look
at my system I got you
so the thing is these people have heavy
usage they're outside they're playing
their system and is wear and tear I
believe is going to really really social
aspect if there was 20% and these were
quite light I don't care how much of a
little crack people are gonna be
tweeting about that they're gonna or you
just don't bear about it I just I just
don't see this ya know go to reddit
reddit has it I've seen it it took me to
put up the topic and I said okay well
you can chew on that into that topic
that was gonna be my topic because a lot
of this people saying like you know with
it with the switch warping on and stuff
like that cuz I have seen a switch
warping where they've shown you know oh
yes which produce much crab the weight
if you put your switch horizontally and
you look at it it's like uneven a lot of
people saying it's a heating issue
shout-out to um I'm all Phillip from the
unintended voice chat it actually like
there's a heating issue that may be
worth it so it could be something from
the dock itself and then we actually
heard about the scratching of the docks
have happened like a long time ago
mm-hmm I don't know it I mean again I'll
free it like over a year like you mean
to tell me like now it's starting to
bend like I don't know a lot of them
been bending like Sue's like early on
I've heard about the warping mind didn't
walk I got a good crack or warp or do
anything weird my joint is playing
normally I didn't have a problem with
the D sinking of the controller it was a
lot of issues that they were talking
about but these weren't issues that are
stopping you from gaming the moment you
stop somebody from doing its intended
purpose I'm sorry but if you just
playing something anything starts
cracking it's an issue whatever reasons
which goes if that's happening it's an
issue why you hurt should happen to you
because if it happened to you I'm pretty
sure that you will be is screaming from
the top of your lungs
it's working like that from the right
from the right at the very top I'm just
saying nothing like that I do think it's
a money issue I agree with King that
it's if it stopping me from playing I
have a big problem now I don't like no
you saw it shouldn't happen that you
deny that it shouldn't happen
it makes an audible sound any product
breaks down by itself like that
regardless how minor it is it needs to
be I'm not saying right now I got the
hairline fracture are you taking if you
did find out if you did find out it's
just which had right to add
I will charge you dollars the figure
crack your cracker hypothetical let's
just say you know you're cleaning around
the house and you move the Xbox one X
and then you turn it around then you
sort hey loud crack in all it next to
the ports in the back would you take it
back at that point guard ooby ain't
telling anybody the chat the hash tag
he'll a fraction when I got my red ring
of death my sister went back if it's
preventing me for gaming winning my
controllers messed up my elites took
them right back you mean it right on me
that my warranty can break if I taken
apart Sola you that's your people is
that everyone got the Kraken like you
know the entire system itself like a
little bit less sturdy like would it be
easier to break at that point like I
don't know like how some would be look
we gotta move
I'm all for Nintendo charging them $100
for the idiot your system not like
breaking down by itself is it isn't us
problem we're moving
may we spread that love in atomic all
right lord addict part me we want to
talk about cross play and go back to
this we go go back to see you know I
will go ahead and let you live King you
know we got a lot of different things I
hate to bring it up I really do but I
feel like you know this is one thing
that's not going away people aren't
talking about it and I just want like
originally I was going to come at this
with you know of what what's the future
with cross progression but now I I would
still want to come for that but I want
to really like go into what do you guys
think like the gaming industry would be
like with cross progression oh alright
just actually thought a lot about this
topic that you eat but first a fantastic
topic and kind of just thinking about
like you know the future in general and
I want to shout out oh my god Mike
Ibarra you know I'm saying a huge friend
to the podcast in the room always great
to see him and on yeah man I think he
made he put a tweet out and I think this
was like last week and he basically said
he really wants cross progression on all
games he says I play on PC and Xbox so
much which all getting supported this
the people I play would do the same we
constantly debate to play new games
together on PC and Xbox just shouldn't
need to be a discussion let's make it
happen so I thought that was a very
powerful tweet and I thought that like
you know it is true like I mean shout
tough J Fonz and these guys too like
these people I know to have you know
destiny they play destiny on every
platform you know I'm saying and like it
just sucks when he comes over
he's lost maybe exotics and things that
he hasn't you know gotten and I'll be
honest like uh you know y'all know I
don't really rocket for buy more of a
pop G guy but of course the switch made
it enticing and it's free so I said I
download it and I tested it just to see
you know me play a game unlock something
get something on a switch and then the
go holds turn on the Xbox right and each
a oh it's like oh this is like the
future yeah and it'll act the last thing
I'll let you drive and the last thing
which is that like I'm not talking about
cross play I think there's people
there's a difference cross progression
with that account to that game is yours
and then goes anywhere regardless of
platform I love it I don't know how to
find Nan's work you know I mean as far
as I would love to get piscatella is our
input on something like this and um you
know as far as from a negative
standpoint does it does it promote
engagement remember when when our
crawler means press play um what's a
game pass when game pass came out right
everyone was worried remember solve
everybody oh you know Xbox is putting
their games on this thing they're gonna
lose sales you know I'm saying but I did
oh hey you know is one of the things
that has been proven you know say we
seems to see at these you seeing steady
chasing regardless of how people feel
about those games they are top MPD and
stuff like that
so the game past didn't affect it it
just created more engagement I would
love to see something like this shout
out to the Chad DJ sing you know I play
warframe on Xbox I would love to play
also my friends on ps4 the same account
you know I'm saying at the very least
yard we don't get cross but I would love
cross progression next-gen I'm just
curious if it hurts any of the
developers there parties or if it hurts
the console makers you know it's too far
why they don't want to do it but it
looks like it's going in this direction
whatever the rest of you guys think
about it I think people I think people
that say that this isn't a thing so
shouldn't be or some of the most like
iconic idiots I've ever seen in my whole
life like because something isn't a
thing it shouldn't be done like
you know how many things you could put
that into like actual history of other
industries like like snuff changes like
landscape of everything changes further
said this year cross progression cross
play not be thing in three years it
could be a universal thing that's
required life thank you no more I think
everything would sell more I would buy
any your copy of destiny if I had to
start over on that's right no I think
that would sell more if I was able to
jump on destiny and just you know my
progression over there no I think in
this generation with what's going on
right now I first of all I don't believe
Sony has the infrastructure that's one
all right so I believe it's the
infrastructure thing that you might say
no they said button thing like they said
it's I don't believe Sony wants it
honestly don't believe when you're the
position of winning if this was last
generation and this topic came up I
believe Sony would have probably been
four it is my opinion if they were
losing right but the fact that you're
winning by such a large margin it gives
you a hubris that you feel like you
don't have to do a lot of things you
don't want to do right I really don't
believe that if they say that they have
exclusive games on their system why
should we help them because they know if
I can take my character and play over
there and let the the hard work here
reckon by a copy on xbox and so I think
they feel that it will probably help our
Xbox in a sense or how about switch and
I think game more users and more NPD
numbers I think that you know I'm
probably wrong but I think that
Microsoft is using cross progression as
a doorway to product across a play
because they want to start marketing
next gen - you don't have to you could
play with your friends anymore anyway
yeah I think they're trying to take
doubt they're trying to make moves now
so they can do something in the future
with it yeah you know that's true they
geniuses because they
using the biggest game in the industry
to push their agenda yeah we all know
you know his services and stuff like
that and I definitely get that um solve
do me a favor just put the coal back in
the check when you attack because I
couldn't find it it's in there looking
like a fool but if when it starts
keeping gamers from doing the intended
purpose of the system that's when it's
gonna become an issue if these people
with OCD have a problem with a hairline
fracture in a system then charge them
the hundred dollars that's fine the JD
gave me saying was the what the hardcore
we need the hawk author forgets that we
are not the first customer of the
platform holders the devs are and
because the devs wanted and it benefits
them they will go there so he's saying
his argument is that it's it's Devon
official but not unless maybe not
necessarily you know hardware platform
beneficial most definitely but the death
in a way that consumers can write and
it's gonna be curious because there's
one game doing well in the cells of that
game dramatically increases because of
it and the dad's gonna be like yo we
need this like this isn't debatable this
is a JD Gaylord JD gamer saying he's
also saying they're going to benefit the
most it doesn't it'll benefit the most
in next-gen when the clock summer sales
resets Sony had better get on board or
get left behind saw was that you talking
yeah yeah so you said cold is out again
and we see this black yeah it comes a
blank yeah right it physical put want me
to put it on the screen yes let me just
write it okay let me just actually write
it you copying and pasting in
you call me from third jump in or what
you finally lets off work but yet oh man
will get his opinion it close enough but
yeah man I mean I think it's the future
I really do
I hope at the other day I think
definitely about now subscribe to it
alright let's see but in the Google
hangout put in the hangout chat man will
do it let's let I have to boss moves
congratulations
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like Moo and let's move is like unless
he's like a hackers favorite song just
type something in the chat you don't
even take them before what is that um
it's a copy-paste thing yeah are you a
moderator he might not be you have
I got you I got you oh it's from
Microsoft so I have it I have it I have
it
just keep talking I don't like imma wait
a couple minutes people got that
unfollow also some crossbow judging
because um what what would you feel I've
been saying this forever man like I it
needs to happen especially and I knew I
the best chance we have for it this Jen
was Microsoft and and switz you know
playing nice with each other well I
agree with these guys I don't think come
I think PlayStation needs to address
this moving forward I don't know not
going a little I don't it's not gonna go
away right but I listen the statement
that they made after saying how they
were gonna deal with the fortnight
fiasco was we're gonna come up with a
solution and you're gonna like it
and that was missing what they said like
so my thing is they're not moving an
inch or they don't want to give Xboxes
any sort of what they perceive to be his
help and if when it comes to the cross
progression thing you're opening the
door for them to be it for somebody to
say you know what
I rather purchase this on this other
system and if I can play it on the
PlayStation that's great
they don't want that they they want to
continue to close garden at least that's
what they're saying so again moving
forward yeah I think it's just it's Xbox
in play and in switch especially a
switch continues to be a different type
of console right right it needs to be
something portable then there's no fear
from from Xbox or even PlayStation that
that there's gonna be that that they're
gonna be they're gonna be whole
down a different part of the market
right you're gonna be able to take it
with you
whereas we don't have that option so
there's not that fear the switch is
gonna override you but Xbox the
PlayStation PlayStation Xbox that's
gonna be a that's an uphill battle
that's enough battle I know Microsoft
wants to do it no problem
Sony hey yeah to see if this becomes the
new model of the future it's gonna be
interesting to see how they respond to
the fortnight thing because I got after
they said that I said what do you mean
you're basically saying we're gonna
address it and whatever we come up with
we trust it you'll be fine with it and
that's that like slowly is gonna be the
only ones left behind in the next
generation when it comes to the
Microsoft ready late day plans flat out
- they tell ya they wanted you to game
everywhere cell phones tablets anything
anywhere so when it comes to that how I
did they don't care if you're playing on
a switch as long as the engagements is
high because they know that you
purchased the game overhead you gonna
play it overhead then you go over there
you play it over there but Sony's idea
of it is archaic in the way that they're
like hoarding their stuff and it's not
gonna work out for but like lordotic
says he doesn't believe that they're
gonna be back really compatible anyway I
don't believe so either yes or more
correct forward compatible
forward-thinking as far as being able to
use your old library into the new
library as well they've never done that
as far as you know doing it without
having a program as far as like
PlayStation now or and you buying a game
over again type of thing um so they're
not consumer friendly when it comes to
that I don't believe that they will
become consumer friendly I believe that
the next system will be a closed
ecosystem and it will push the
generation forward because it will be
able to focus heavily on the CPUs and
the stuff that's in the system so they
do they care about cross progression no
is it on the agenda no it's a
cross-platform playing on the agenda
no they believe in their in their own
bubble and it will stay that way I
believe so I believe they will be left
because of that philosophy mmm
interested so that's what we got on
cross progression great topic Lord
addict Lord King inside Xbox and pub G
was inside inside Xbox I don't watch
don't watch
I think it's contrived and disgusting I
rather watch a Nintendo Direct I will
watch that Smash brother direct / I do
not care about that anyway but I did
watch it from beginning to end looking
for pub G was none to be found though
pub G on the public test servers it they
have launched a big patch it was 11 gigs
and it brought it closer to the PC so
right now if you're playing on an X
you're getting the for 4k experience at
30 frames per second and also a lot of
the overlays and a lot of the changes
that they did to the weapons the
grenades the vehicles so everything is
getting closer to that PC launch and um
how I see it is I think they're closing
everything or bottling everything up so
they can get purchased by Microsoft and
if anybody got a chance to play on the
public set servers because it goes live
after the 16th from so it's from the
10th to the 16th that they get a chance
to play on on the test service to see
these new implementations into the
system and has the numbers dwindled I
believe so the engagement numbers is
lower but I think everybody's just
gearing up for the actual physical
launch
of the gang to being in this PlayStation
preview so my question was is it
affecting at this long gestation period
of the system of the game is it
affecting them being that is out on PC
you know what the sales be lower when it
actually really releases an Xbox we feel
about it I sorry I was doing something
of what pretty much talk about the
latest updates to pop G and um you know
as far your whole thing is in reference
to the PC as well King or just the Xbox
minecraft days mm-hmm right they're
pretty close well or summers you see any
of the information on what you call it
uh club G at all as far as any of the
updates yeah I mean to me I just the
King's point to this question honestly I
think sales are not I don't think I
wanna see stays scaled excuse me sales
skyrocket or go out there scale sky just
because I think the game it's from where
the game is right now 21.0 I don't think
it's gonna be such a huge leap day at
this point if you want to play that game
you're gonna feel bad about paying that
money to play that game now may be
launched but you've seen the amount of
updates the game has gotten since launch
like they've been on top of updating
that game and they we already knew who's
gonna be on a different like my cadence
standard than the pc version i don't see
sales jumping and people think oh the
game's finally out officially 1.0 i
don't think the product you're getting
at 1.0 is vastly different than what
you're gonna get after these next
updates like with the snow level and all
that to me i don't necessarily like
people always try to say like budgies
dead but then you want steam it's like
the third most played game on Steam last
time I checked on Xbox was like number
five I was surprised by the
like fortnight's killing it that's
definitely right but at the end of the
day it's like the Xbox you don't have to
be first to make money
no absolutely make money absolutely
shout out to the Lord fixed R to trap
troll and his club G running above 30
frames per second X yet it's a good
point
better than zero resolution you guys
think that to buy them now i think the
kiss move man he had a video i think on
this to tweet on it as well i know you
know it's interesting because it's it's
like I know everything that the
narrative and us get into our family
feeling sometimes with the whole pub G
versus fortnight but like you said Soph
you made a good like its salad like it
and like I said it's still the
engagement is still high like number
five when Xbox was still nothing you
know this thing about you know sneeze
about and my whole thing is this I want
to shout out to more I wanna shout out
Lord uh Tim gone and he had a tweet in
reference to almond just did the whole
you know obviously a lot of people still
are upset you know with the performance
issues and the patches and stuff like
that and you know from what he was told
and it seemed like it came out that the
only way they can really really get to
this thing is if they kind of switch
engines or revamp the engine completely
almost like a rebuild that investments
gonna have to be made right rumor is
that Brandon green and those guys a blue
hair going to start that process now so
the you know I don't know if it's gonna
affect the current pub G or maybe the
next iteration but from what I'm hearing
he he was told that the only way because
everybody said hey what's going on watch
this thing you know still struggling as
far as performance and that's what I
that's what you know the rumor is and
then the second thing I want to bring
out is a shout the Lord ran out Thor cuz
I'm in shock to the Xbox to him I let a
podcast with just going who's that
so it's like he made a point he's
hardcore babji like just like a Iran
gets it in well apparently I don't know
something some recent update happening
in now I'm played a little while but
they were saying like is the framerate
issue there's some issue that is kind of
pissing people off right now
and a couple of his hardcore group with
like a I'm done with it or what have you
so I'm very curious to see with you know
now it getting close you know how that
affects the game okay so he fix now okay
cool in the preview game when they did
update it started affecting the
framerate yes right it became to the
point they was like oh man back to this
again type of thing and then when I
played the public test server this week
because I went in there by myself I said
yeah let me see
you know the updates and all the stuff
and it was like night and day completely
night and dick is all played the the
preview version and I was like oh they
need to do this by the 16 out of 16 for
you get what's inside the test server up
inside the preview game a shocker
elevator he also said um he said like
almost like a week or two then they had
the issue so since then it's been pretty
much resolved right real quick um I know
you gonna jump on approach I just want
to I know he never let's talk about
instead Xbox I'm just gonna make a real
quick comment I did catch it
um addict has a great video out right
now please check it out on how to fix it
you know I'm an agreement with a lot of
his points I think that ultimately it's
still too long it's still too corny and
there's some decent announcements um you
know and I'm still happy that it exists
don't get me wrong I like that the door
maybe I read but I am
because you said oh I don't know with
the baby you force me to talk about that
crack-a-lackin' you know I go into blood
and sovereign put a like a weird comment
that was in like it's gonna be jokes I
say you know what let me just watch this
stupid direct actually call it a direct
because it should be like a direct it
should be in the format of a direct
Petite they want to make personality all
right he's not interesting in person I'm
not gonna shout you out
nobody knows what I'm talking about but
they're trying to push you as the next
hottest ladies you are not it bro I met
you it's super corny you can actually be
you may be to come off better and that's
probably what they banking on that
you're gonna turn into you at some point
in time but right now you're stinking it
up is making it super wack and I get so
upset I draw watching with the sound off
aw addicts I know he's ready
it's just that like you know what it is
for me I don't like the life or
I think they need to record the show and
then edit that the Lord and the bushes I
think that's just what it is it still
needs to be condensed it like my cooking
said it to me needs to be a direct
format and just boom boom boom boom boom
get us in get us out
that's it like this laughs don't get me
wrong the production value is hot like
I'm not disrespecting it but it's just I
look at that they put a chandelier in
the background doesn't make it hot
it's taste like you had a great video it
is [ __ ] don't talk about it I feel like
that inside Xbox is unfairly criticized
because people expect like III
announcements every week every month I
feel like the majority of the reason
this was even created was for game pass
mm-hmm I think that we'll see a lot more
of inside Xbox next gen mm-hm
and I'll not shout out to Mike Rivera he
he low-key just posted IOP shirt oh I
literally just refresh Twitter sorry I
completely interrupted the podcast but
gets daggits love the mega bar man
good I think we'll see inside Xbox be
more relevant next generation yeah I
mean guys how did you get chopped off
with that with this Wow yo Mike Ibarra
shut yo shout out the bar y'all we got
to put this off this is legendary band
salute to the lord of it all Wow why are
we gonna have to put this up you keep
talking I'm gonna get it for you I mean
listen like the show I agree I just I
don't need to see the personalities just
give me something like a direct give me
the information like although all the
forces stuff
I don't think though I think the issue
it's the way they present it lying yes
like I get that I can't they want to be
funny but they're not but yes that's not
their late it's like it's okay it's okay
to have like some you know funny moments
in it oh don't try to have them people
be funny like like I think what they
need to stick with inside Xbox as it
needs to stick to the interview format
it needs to have that they need to keep
the community aspect and because I do
think the black dudes funny Mike Ibarra
put it up y'all
that's a so I thought that they're not
funny I feel like they try to force it
and that makes it not funny
mmm Howard directing that it's wait a
second Mike Ibarra baby when i retweeted
that no I was so busy in what I was
doing because I was on Instagram oh
thank you so much man I appreciate I
really do it's the first time he hit me
up last week and he said hey man you
know he didn't know that we have
obviously affiliated with tick and that
he didn't realize that you do go live
the day before so he was catching the
episodes a week after and then he you
know he put the timeline again so yeah
how can I catch on like take that work
that's when you get it first as far as
the podcast is concerned so salute the
Lord cat daddy that man was on a roll
and we really appreciate you man that
that means very humble bro very humble
thank you so much and salute the Mikey
borrowing a - whoo man that this is
humbling today really know that was what
I was retweeting yeah like the Lord's
Day something you know i retweeted it
because I always retweet everybody I'm
more like a fool for retweeting I'm late
don't care who you are if you if I'm in
it I'm gonna like and I'm gonna retweet
it sometimes I gotta look cause I got
some weird stuff going on with this
battery going too far with his battery
stuff but wow man I'm so happy that he
even like this shirt man I really I
really so yeah just to finish up the
inside Xbox topic yeah I agree with all
the laws I mean this is still to me
still work in progress I'm appreciative
that it exists let's be clear though I
don't get me wrong not that I want it to
go away because that the complaint
before was you know we don't know
anything until III right I think addict
is on it though that it seems to be a
great platform for game pass and then
the kind of really bring this thing
forward so I like that aspect of it and
I want to shout out arm as far as the
arm to get the dolby vision though and
get that that look that's a good look
now cuz at the end of the day you know
we have the HDR competing formats the
HDR 10 and Dolby vision and for xbox to
be so full at thinking and to at least
not know right now people like it is
just video is not gameplay but just for
it to be for thinking to give people who
have those Dobby vision only sets to be
able to at least you know utilize it
that's great
you know I'm saying as far as Forza
horizon for a shout-out to deaf singing
look fantastic and I'm saying far as
wedding stuff like that to change and
see if you know forth for us is gonna do
for us like Forza is the great you know
racing platform just a lot of us you
know Hawk well we don't care for it as
much so it doesn't be like any whatever
for us but it's it's fantastic and then
only the end of the day they got the
best racer in the entire on a platform
period and they were confident to turn
they bought them because they were good
they were doing so much I want to say
something too I was a little upset
though saw with the with he has Sean
Murray on with no man sky right it
really wasn't it was it'd be like they
did show a lot of the next features I
felt no I don't know how ready that
stuff is when I this is the opportunity
for that game to get you know a second
chance
mmm-hmm with
with you know on a console that hasn't
had it no you know you got a I
understand the trepidation and bigging
it up really like making it seem like
it's a huge thing like you know what I
mean because we know what happened when
it when they originally did that but
yeah they should have shown more you
should have made it and I'm glad that
you know Sean Murray's out from under
his rock and he not afraid to come out
and have people because he disappears
for a while because people were really
getting we had cloud power oh no was
just frito what we got do we have a few
story mode yes that game we saw that
weirdness that reminded you sort of a
Bioshock and then when the game went
into early access it was all that
survival stuff and and it was like this
is not what I saw like you know yeah so
that they did have something in the work
so this is what I'm interested in this
game for that they were like I feel like
we happy few like that Trello me
obviously they showed us some litt [ __ ]
when the games and it never showed up in
the game but you know like then show me
that in that direction if that game is
anything like that I could see the make
of some bomb games for Microsoft yeah
it's off I just like the the variety in
the that the studios that they picked up
yes you have guys that can make huge
games small games like you they have a
great variety there and they're not done
right and I
so I just think these guys they got
talent man there's a lot of talent here
[Laughter]
so I'm so fed up with the fact that
being an xbox stand
you gotta really start acknowledging
this like that's spider-man no one can
tell me and listen know what I say when
I see god of war looks like wow I just
posted up a video of that spider-man
that spider-man I can't wait for the day
it drops because you won't see me on
xbox and I won't be live on PlayStation
because I do not have you could talk on
PSN with no oh okay so then I can talk
to you but I don't have a headset so you
just plug this one in did you get the
500 this time out this last time I give
you my Fox to smell finish right now I'm
sorry to keep going on this tangent
because I'm truly I'm hurt like because
we got games and they play nice
really
no I don't even believe the trailers
when the games come out anymore that's
not real till I can see Detroit and I
play Detroit and I'm like we can't take
anything away from Sony dev teams I mean
no studios and what bar log and these
guys have done with what God award what
you know these guys have done with
Detroit and Cajun those guys Quantic
Dream and now he's like Sam that quits
with all what you call it it's truly for
now ok good and the sad part is like I
don't you think we need like games it's
like storage oven like that like we do
need something like I feel like what
I've been told they put in the kind of
budget behind fable that's like that
kind of looting the thing that I am
looking for for the next generation
systems though in reference to these
Xbox games that will be coming out by
these Studios is I do feel the CPU
bottleneck does hinder a lot of stuff
and Beyond and we ask the question we
asked a co-op tethering question from
undead labs you know shout out the phone
you gotta bring him back a tremendous
tremendous show and um you know he did
say that one of the things is just you
know memory and CPU constraints to
manage you know four independent yes the
GPU has improved right on the tremendous
but the CPU is still but it's still an
older processor and at the end of the
day that's the limitation that's what
prevents water yeah believe so though is
it
the overclock ex equivalent to the
PlayStation pros Drago isn't it more
power and more a CPU power it did more
than the probe pretty much it's pretty
much it can we uh just quick question of
this we just dropped the fortnight
season five I woke up and I just
realized by exto and it's at the point
right now the Spider Man is coming it's
right there it's right around the corner
and these were these games so you come
full circle since the beginning of the
podcast no no I don't agree with it in a
sense I know why I have an X that's what
is that sound like about five seconds
ago
you can back step easy you don't even
need a Baxter my my thing is top right
thing is if it's more powerful right
right just give me one game this
generation foot that X okay you wanna
power
I do think get it I do think there's a
baseline to what games should look like
for every gen and like stated okay as
much as I love it
it was a little bit below the baseline
where game she's little like in the Xbox
one right right let's move on that's the
obvious of you head off points on this
right trust me I think I'm not gonna be
talking this for at night like like like
breaking fortnight down don't worry
buddy
sovereign final topic okay
Oh fortnight season five what's going on
so as Lord addicts say
let me preface every third in the bush
yeah let me preface everything I'm gonna
say we were to disclaimer right yes I'm
soft I have not played fortnight nor do
I know if I will ever play for broad
confirm keep them with you I'm firmly in
the camp that says F epic for taking
advantage of the business that
relationship they have what is this
topic keep going to copy their pub G
blueprint into their game right not a
bit of an ethical thing exact way better
exactly they do basically they gain it
was dead in the water
louis another poet in the bushes watches
the truth of the matter is that these
guys you know they weren't rushing out
to make a battle royale game when people
were playing the culling and you know
h1z1 or days you know they went and made
a battle royal game after they had
access to prove these ancient and so
listen I guess apologies engine you mean
their engine their engine exactly well
access to pump you know they got ahold
of their deal
again so I'm not in their corner when it
comes to that but that said if you're
going to blatantly rip off a concept and
make it your own then you should improve
upon it and that's why I gotta give them
credit for not battle royal is polished
it's on everything with cross-play or
NIT war on nearly all devices with
cross-play not not all mmm-hmm it's by
all accounts from the play as I said I
had not played the game it's free so how
would you know is polish you just
looking at it is possible everything
that you can buy in that game is
cosmetic yes and it's extremely well
supported and that's what I want to
focus on the support model that this
game
I think it's really where it's brilliant
what epic manages to do on a weekly and
a seasonal like update model with the
arg implementation do these what these
guys are done you know updates quicker
than all the city what they do in this
game is they create like a sense of
narrative and continue story in a game
and in a game mode that doesn't need it
battle royale doesn't need all this
quote-unquote stories type stuff right
geniuses that's absolutely and then by
doing this they create a level of
investment and nao here's that dirty
word again that we always use engagement
I love engagement world dead they it
goes beyond what you would expect from a
battle royale game right just just it's
ridiculous so if you look at everything
epic is done leading up to the season
five right with that that rocket launch
that caused a rift in the sky and then
the formation of the smaller rifts which
then in turn they made things in the
world disappear or be destroyed things
appeared in the real world yeah and all
this Arg they're doing like mind you
energy isn't for everybody right all
salute Thank You chief Tommy thank you
so much man appreciate you so much thank
you continue look at what they've done
like with Arg and how they keep you like
Arg isn't for everybody right like
that's for the hardcore the hardcore to
go out there and figure out all this
craziness but the beauty of that is that
they bring all the information back to
everybody who's not as hardcore about
that just wants to play the game and all
that information is for everybody to use
right so what they've done is they
create like a continuous narrative
thread through the game that makes
players feel like like they unlocking
the mysteries of the world right like
bugs in a very organic way and my point
to all this is that this is very
different to how the shared war games
that we've been playing until now like
destiny the division even Monster Hunter
and maybe what ant
is gonna be it's very different to how
they they they disseminate story in
their games right and this is my whole
point to this is that all of these games
need to look too epic and for tonight
battle royal and how they handle
narrative in that game hmm and basically
copy that because think about it it is
what are the issues people have with
destiny what are the issues people have
with wit narrative and how that
narrative is given to you right they
give it a face game when you buy it and
you play all of that information
and then you wait months for that
whatever the big content drop is right
and then you'll get more story in that
and that's that's how stories just
dropped in those games same for the
division they even monster hunter where
they try to create like this continuous
world but then with monster hunter you
go and you like okay we have the we have
Ryu we have we have Megaman and then you
have this upcoming Final Fantasy like 14
type crossover thing but it's not really
expanding on the world of monster hunter
the way it can be and if the discussions
we had around anthem about how what's
gonna happen with no PvP what if that
what if the story content is short and
what are you going to be doing in that
game what does yeah what this game does
they need to copy this flat-out because
if you come out imagine destiny 1 right
you play the initial but whatever
destiny was initially right and then a
week later they give you something
happens in the world like some comets
coming out of the sky everybody in the
game can see this they're like yo let's
go to that location where the hell is
that comet going em lands it causes some
kind of thing in the world that
everybody can see everybody can react to
and it all of these little these little
strange create mysteries within the
world that open up the narrative and
lead to the other things that make the
game keep you invested in the game in a
way that the way they drop narrative now
doesn't do people will play all this
stuff rock it out and then walk away
that's a good point
Katinka now I'll jump in first of all
from all the sales that they sold which
probably is in the billions they lowered
the price of the tools for anybody that
wants to
use that engine no because of how much
money you know they poppins they did
that they said they want everybody in
the world to use their tools and they
lowered the price because of hey we
don't need money mom okay
that there's a business move there right
but this is why they're able to do what
what you're talking about and why
destiny won't do it and why other games
won't do it these are the sole
controllers of the engine in the house
that they work in right so they're able
to produce this information and this
stuff out at a rapid pace
in a business model that is economic for
them because they can throw a bigger
stake opposed to activision and Bungie
and another company so I know you would
like that to happen across the boards
but unless a company controls the engine
then reducing that controls the house
that they work in and the workers and
the game they're the sole controllers
and they push it out on other systems
it's on every platform doing numbers on
every platform able to do what you want
the funny thing is all right this is
what I would want but I agree with you
completely I think they're the only ones
that in the position to be able to give
that amount of support on a weekly basis
because this is weekly air this is
different let me let me tell you how to
it real quick because as a switch owner
I've been having problems with my switch
lately I'll jump on I mean you know I'll
take it out to dock I'm ready to go to
work and I mean I'm not out to dial just
you know take it out the case and ready
to go to work and I look at the battery
life like why is my battery always down
I like 27 percent all of a sudden and I
just could it was really driving me
crazy until I had a talk with kai Basu
and he's like yeah for tonight's
probably updating a lot that if you
really cuz normally like mitosis which
supports the background downloading
you're getting all the time all the time
all the time and I'm like you're my
switch can't take what I literally bus
which was like I am
is that it now it's like it is the
frequency that level of support Africa's
given it and it's just really cool you
know me and just to see that across the
board and and just like besides that
whole thing you're saying saw which is
like this this narrative induced thing
in the world right and it's just like
wow like they have created a story in a
non narrative game a battle royal game
and it's just interesting and it's very
go and to be honest you know it doesn't
get enough credit I feel was before that
when they had Thanos with the Infinity
Gauntlet remember it was those crazy
crazy marketing that's how you know they
that's when you know what you got when
you got drink you know how you know they
making money
it wasn't like three or four months
after infinity war it was like the
weekend before yeah like you've cow man
is when it comes to market you like that
they're not gonna let you they don't
want you taking like the shine off their
movie they're like nah man like you're
just perfect perfect timing when it when
they dropped with infinity war and it's
like they're on it man it on you can't
take anything away from it it's a
marketing movement it's a electing said
they are so controls at that engine so
those updates come out fast I mean just
impressive even way before that 4k
beyond X looks like wow like I was like
alright I got at least yesterday after
enough time it's gotten big enough roll
I can't ignore it any you can't ignore
everywhere and shop the loss in you know
he's a story to PB is good but just now
and I love Microsoft and Nintendo were
playing so nice because it's so cool
be at work do something at 4:00 and
fortnight come home fire up the eggs but
you don't say you got no excuse
yes bro they forced my hand like there
was no way I could not play it because
I'm like I play switch all right cool
cross play and cross progression and
what I like shout out to Mike Ibarra
Lord in the realm I like that they're
really pushing cross progression like we
said in the earlier topic that's the
wave man daddy could you imagine you
know I don't laugh but could you bad you
like all the destiny at 220 PS oh it's
just so cool man I mean to see that kind
of thing and that not like that's
ultimately solve what we wanted the Vita
to be remember absolutely you know play
the Vita anymore I can't that's pretty
much why God on it man I think this is
great I think this is great stuff you're
gonna see the continued the momentum
that they have and how they gonna go
with it but um yeah we gotta wrap this
up all right sorry
let's get us out of here bear this was a
long one you know saying apologize guys
yeah I think something hopefully lost
our bond is okay and we'll get him back
on the show and uh schedules allow but
with a new ILP poll for the week when
Microsoft execs
this is crazy how timing is up this
question it games like a fortnight
pushing the idea of cross progression
how important is cross possession to you
as a gamer to have this feature a cross
progression is an overblown feature not
mandatory be cross professed progression
is the future of gaming or see I don't
care it's fake concern because Xbox of
switches losing them MPD sales please
rock the aisle tomorrow obviously like I
said salute to all the chat today
more in the realm cat-daddy or a new
patreon supporters Lord Xbox quick in
the building men oh yes
traumatic time a tremendous support we
really appreciate job and we love the
job you don't not the moves for being
the troll he is the boss movie it should
help with the battery life oh my gosh of
the Calla teach everybody a chat with
tremendous yeah kept us rocking today
really want to salute that in it and
like I said the new patreon subscribers
it really means a lot to my cube are for
where guy about piece humbling man so
home that means you have no idea how
much that means to us and like I said
just really appreciate you guys rocking
when I said we gonna keep trying to keep
building and give you guys the best
content you cking out here social media
you got the stream team when addicts
solve the Lord Pei Xian of iron bank and
that I am P you know I mean rockin man
that's really starting probably the week
after next yes sir yes all right so what
Lord actually a couple of them are
actually in the chat well I know one of
them is uh shout out to l-boogie I know
she's one of them buggy that's killing
them softly you know we did have another
one Lord PD he's gonna be as well smiley
and I what's the UH the third the third
one's name yeah I don't want to butcher
the name player yes yes between our ILP
you know you know what games you would
like them to stream you know we'll take
that in consideration we're not gonna
guarantee that they stream those games
but we'll definitely take that in
consideration because you know IOPS
always we want to support the community
that's the whole point of this and you
know the streamers like to stream that
will definitely try to make sure that
happens absolutely definitely yeah
the big one put up pictures put up yes
please do and oh shout to locate Megan
to check a senior bro I've met him out
there and III man tremendous stuff let's
do our trap he's got to get a Lord
addict what's going on with you working
a find people find you now uh you won't
follow me on PlayStation this week but
you'll find me on xbox I've been trying
to go back to the Mario Odyssey thing
but I'm not really feeling it too much
mhm
definitely I've been playing a little
bit of PC I'm gonna really get down on a
couple of things I got some stuff though
now it's here soon I keep an eye out for
the IOP and uh my personal Twitter will
be announcing more stuff on the on the
streaming team I got a we're still
looking for a fourth person so if you
think your elevant native asking west he
wants info on stream team oh it's going
to be on the Abbaye one in the chat
feels like they are they um they can
stream definitely hit me up whoa we'll
take your credential see if favorite
things good on that and say ah me play
at the end of the day like you know I'm
not I do want I do have some criterias
to stream but you know we'll go into all
that definitely appreciate definitely
see okay mega command appreciate
everyone that jump I you know it's been
it's been we do this for the community
we definitely appreciate everyone that
shows why another shout out to fat stack
so that that's probably the most I've
ever seen anyone super fat thanks for
that we'll see you next week absolutely
Luis Avila no and what can I find people
find you I
Lord servile people on Twitter I'm not
gonna say the other stuff because I have
not been on there
hahaha not on the platforms of late but
up a big shout-out to cat daddy finally
making a live show I know it's tough for
him that's okay and silent so are all
our new patrons like really it's amazing
and so I also get you guys in the chat
every single week man you guys make this
show you guys this show there's no doubt
about it dr. Aaron summers who got us
all arguing set up like a Q&A one time
for the absolutely thank you guys and uh
oh yeah bomb chicken go Lord Pei Xian
iron bank Holness down that's what's up
Lord King man what you got going in our
that combat talk look lik thank you
appreciated I just took your advice I
got a good video editing software and
also echo echo machine I don't want to
say proper shot on next because we
working with him in conjunction knows
fantastic work he worked very hard and
worked very quickly and very
passionately he's always in contact so
you never lose contact with him at all
times I mean this man stays up all night
so I do want to thank him for bringing
my vision to fruition so I do appreciate
everything that he did so as far as
getting that stuff out first and
foremost Facebook Instagram Twitter what
is that a twitch mm-hmm an Instagram we
are there and it's called iron Lord
podcast all over the place so you can't
mix the name up you can't mess the name
up is not what is Z's not with a little
podcast
so people get that then soon the link is
gonna pop up for these t-shirts and
these cops and all this wonderful stuff
that you can get the iron Lords brand on
it on combat talk is on the channel and
I die Opie panel you can jump on there
right now there's two episodes up
they're not long they're short you know
why they're short because I get to the
point and I talk about exactly what you
want to hear and I give my predictions
um we're gonna be doing expanding is
it's growing I'm gonna have ideas with
it I'm talk with J Fonzarelli that's my
guy lavon's so you know he's gonna bring
in that aspect of the the UFC so when I
say combat sports I'm not just talking
about box and I'm talking about
everything MMA is gonna be involved well
probably get some kickboxing no but if
you can catch two bombs fighting we're
passionate about this is about pure
gaming and when I say the word period
gaming those words that phrase pure
gaming gaming at its purest level when
you first picked up a controller what we
want to bring back we want to bring back
that sense of oneness like wonder like
wow did you worry
Sony head or Xbox said you were a gamer
so yeah get back to pure gaming oh man
well said well said in that that's what
we trying to promote man it's out the
King on the combat talking handling the
UH so should be first of all that
Instagram is late I want to give you a
lot of credit on that a lot of nostalgic
pictures or pictures of the Lords at
events running around just you know cool
gaming stuff and we gonna have more
coming up man I'm know I want to start
contributing to that Instagram as well
because a lot of those pictures really
brought back a lot of memories
I said differently threes just fun stuff
man so that was really a great idea
about a king and we respect that but
yeah man like I said shout out to
everybody in chat it was tremendous on
like I said you guys hit that like and
subscribe and the patreon is amazing it
really helps us so we got more stuff
coming and announcements on the way also
I want to shout out more about so he's
gonna get that audio up
later on tonight we put timestamps from
like tui threes ago on this Instagram
yeah it's the gram is amazing man please
he's got like eg 2015 20 2016 not like
the worst pictures I've ever took on
this yeah I got one of addict with some
Deadpool chick and I swear when I put it
up everybody's like you that's the first
time we ever seen more addicts my little
also like I said I channel a lot of new
exciting content up there you still got
more III content and we still have to
put up there as well as well as our
flashpoint y'all 23 with my man Lord he
bounces up hardcore destiny so oh and of
course that's married with the combat
talk that we can be given to your that's
it it's gonna be on Saturdays first
predictions in this Sunday morning after
the fight how's how's it working goes
then I'm gonna give my predictions
because I don't give predictions until
after I see the way before then we're
gonna get fight breakdowns so stupid
fights like triple G versus a fight
break down or what each guy has to do to
win and then on the day of the weigh-in
then I'm gonna give my prediction and
after that in the morning
you did it you said it you said it shout
out to everybody that man fantastic I
said great content please support both
challenge the inner circle Network and
of course the normal podcast YouTube
channel I know we went late everybody if
anything got anything else to say no all
right everybody enjoy your Sunday is the
Lord's Day and we are peace